this is like your astrology 101 yeah by
the time we leave here you are going to
be an astrologer yeah no absolutely like
i i fully admit i do not know a lot
about australia you don't need to know i
do believe in it though really like it
makes sense to me
hi eliza i'm tom hi tom i'm elisa nice
to meet you nice to meet you what do you
think fire sign means in astrology um
it's uh
something to do with the sun
it could be
yeah so there's three fire signs there
are aries
leo and sagittarius and
these are the fire signs we also have
water signs which is like the scorpio
moon we have air signs and then we have
earth signs so there are four elements
in astrology okay this is like your
astrology 101. i do believe in it though
really yeah because i understand that
you know there's gravitational pull from
planets and tides and all sorts of
things like that so how would that not
affect you in some way you know when
you're
developing and all of that and being
born right
yeah so i believe in it
if you were to define mercury retrograde
based on what other people say how would
you define it well it's i mean just
going from memory from the last few
times it's happened it's always been
like if everything's kind of topsy-turvy
and things are weird and people maybe
you're not getting along or or
bad things are happening or whatever
it's always you know people can always
sort of conveniently say oh no no it's
it's not my fault it's it's mercury's in
retrograde that's an excuse a good
excuse it's a great excuse for bad
behavior so you get three weeks four
times a year when you can blame all of
your disasters on mercury retro yeah i
love that i've got some stuff i can
blame on something else
mercury uh is the planet of
communication so it's really like
interpersonal relationships
you know contracts and then it also
rules things like traffic and machinery
and electronics okay that that's so so
random events that not even
inconveniences yeah random inconvenience
random inconveniences are the stuff of
mercury retrograde oh that's good and
that's nice because then
you know when you lose your passport
it's not your fault anymore exactly
what do you think the difference is
between a new moon and a full moon uh
is uh
the top of the month or something like
that so this is when you are up in the
country you are going to really know now
because during a new moon there is no
nocturnal illumination interestingly
enough i uh i live in one of the dark
sky areas yeah one of actually possibly
one of the more dark sky areas in the
world
and i actually just recently talked
about being psychic maybe i knew this
was going to happen we were going to
have this conversation but i just
recently took a picture of the blue moon
the full moon
with my telephoto lens and actually sent
it to drew because we were we were
chatting about it and i sent her this
picture wow so that's kind of weird a
coincidence right actually was weird i
don't say a thing because there are no
coincidences exactly so
this is one of those very interesting
not a coincidence coincidence so that
was a blue moon
yes so a blue moon happens when there's
two full moons in the same zodiac sign
okay so we had one during leo season
actually we had a full moon at the
beginning of leo season and a full moon
at the end of leo season so that second
one is called a blue moon okay so that's
during a full moon when you have total
visibility
a new moon is at the beginning of a
lunar cycle and it's when the sky is
completely dark so it's an amazing time
for stargazing it's amazing time for
reflecting for sort of internal
processing because during a full moon
you have light shining on everything so
you can see things clearly you go on my
instagram you can see the the blue moon
and then you can also see these really
amazing night uh astral photography
shots uh from the dark sky in the
country where i live wow have you been
spotting jupiter and saturn
uh you know i i have i just didn't know
which ones they were no i've been i've
been meaning to get uh i haven't gotten
around i have done this before but
actually i haven't gotten around to this
at my new place to get out the the star
chart if the moon is in aquarius and you
look up you can see
jupiter and you can see saturn because
they're both in aquarius next to it so
during like a nice full moon you'll be
able to see both of them and what's that
mean the age of aquarius so we just
entered that yeah now
just now just now not in the 70s believe
it or not they jumped the gun a little
bit so that wasn't even so that whole
they were excited the song and
everything well it just
they're a little ahead of the time
started celebrating a few decades too
early exactly
so
tom did you learn anything new i think i
did i think i did actually with some
good information i'm happy to have
learned it i'm i did not know i was a
scorpio moon as well as a leo which is
gonna be nice to tell people that it
kind of explains a lot when you talked
about sort of the
sort of the yin and yang of my
personality i was always sort of a
little bit uh confused by you know the
leo character traits that were didn't
fully encapsulate who i am so so that's
nice to know thank you so much
[Music]
you